the Marvels have landed the first teaser
for the newest MCU Adventure which
brings together Carol Danvers Monica
Rambo and Kamala Khan is packed with
treats for fans with Keen eyes the
internet at large is fascination with
cat videos is proof that a cute feline
is often a welcome addition to anything
make the cat in Eldritch tentacle
Abomination and suddenly one has the
Fearsome creature known as a flirkin
though these beings appear to be simple
house cats flarkins are actually
incredibly intelligent and contain
pocket Dimensions that allow them to
hide their deadly tentacles
the cat this isn't what you're afraid of
is it that's not a cat this species was
originally introduced to the MCU in
Captain Marvel by way of goose who
nobody initially realizes is an alien
but it soon becomes apparent how
dangerous these creatures are in the
teaser trailer for the Marvels Kamala is
quickly introduced to Goose's true
nature much to her horror for fans of
Captain Marvel it's great to see Goose
back in action but it also appears that
there might be an entire litter of
flirkin kittens running about which
isn't adorable yet terrifying Prospect
for any foe it will be fascinating how
these deceptive and cunning creatures
fit into the movie's greater plot
from Marvel's laboratory to the Kiln the
mcu's characters love to visit
space-based facilities whenever the
opportunity presents itself and with the
Marvels set to explore the cosmos the
franchise is adding a space station to
the mix the opening moments of the
Marvel's teaser trailer takes place on
the saber space station which looks a
whole lot like the Comics headquarters
of sort the sentient World observation
and response Department Shields
space-based counterpart in the MCU
Monica Rambo's Mother Maria founded
sword and Monica served as a sword agent
in one division the MCU acronym is
slightly different from the comics with
The W standing for weapon with these
Scrolls set to play a major role in the
future of the MCU it's entirely possible
that the saber space station will be
used to explore their corner of the
Galaxy for now the station's purpose is
unknown although Kamala does Wonder
is an Avengers test although one might
assume that the Marvels will showcase
three different variations of the same
Powers each character has a unique set
of skills that are born from their
specific Origins Carol gains hers from
exposure to an experimental energy
source Kamala gets hers from a bangle in
combination with her alien Heritage and
Monica's Powers come from repeated
forays across Wanda maximoff's energy
barrier around West View in one division
Kamala can create hard light constructs
and Carol can harness a powerful
Galactic power source Monica meanwhile
explains that she can manipulate light
energy which allows her to project
energy blasts as well as become
intangible considering her comic book
counterpart who is sometimes called
photon is able to control energy on the
entire electromagnetic spectrum Monica
stands to develop even more Powers over
the course of the Marvels either way
she's sure to be a powerful hero
making use of alien technology is a
recurring trend for shield from the very
first Avengers movie it becomes apparent
that Earth is hopelessly outgunned and
outmatched on an Intergalactic scale so
Nick Fury has no qualms with Scavenging
weapons research from Hydra or
experimenting on the Tesseract to
develop a powerful new energy source
that would better defend Earth from
Alien invasions and interdimensional
Warlords at the beginning of the teaser
trailer for the Marvel's Monica reports
on her proximity to the perimeter of a
jump point which shows that Earth is
experimenting with jump technology this
type of technology is featured
predominantly in the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise and it is the means by
which space-faring beings travel quickly
Across the Universe although the jump
Point shown in the teaser trailer
doesn't seem to be nearly as refined or
Advanced as the universal neural
teleportation Network depicted in
Guardians its mere appearance implies
that Earth is quickly catching up to the
rest of the universe considering the
sheer number of aliens who have
interacted with Earth over the past
decade or so it makes perfect sense as
to why shield and fear would want to
learn as much as they can as quickly as
they can whether or not earth develops
this technology independent of outside
influences anybody's guess but it is
reassuring that humanity is rapidly
advancing
2023 is looking to be a big year for
Nick Fury the super spy and former
director of Shield seems to be getting
cozy up in space but his eye patch May
signal when the Marvels takes place in
the MCU timeline in late March 2023
Vanity Fair dropped a piece on the
secret invasion in which Jackson said
his character sheds the iconic eye patch
in the Disney plus series as part of his
character development making it seem
like the accessory will become a relic
of the past however in the Marvel's
teaser trailer Fury is still wearing his
eye patch meaning that the sequel almost
certainly takes place before the events
of secret invasion in the MCU timeline
Marvel Studios most recent release
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is the
latest event in the MCU timeline with
black panther wakanda forever before it
and Thor love and thunder in the
timeline before that presumably the
Marvels will take ant-man's place as the
most recent MCU entry though it does
also seem to take place at least
partially immediately after the Ms
Marvel Disney plus series it seems like
Marvel planned for the Marvels to come
out before secret Invasion or at least
at roughly the same time but that's not
the case secret Invasion debuts June
21st while Marvels is slated for
November 10th after being pushed back
from a July release that said neither
story is likely to suffer because of the
shake-up in the release schedule but it
will be interesting to see a grizzled
Nick Fury taking on the Scrolls before
teaming up with the lighthearted Kamala
Khan in the Marvels that's assuming Nick
Fury in the trailer actually is the real
Nick Fury and not a scroll like in
Spider-Man far from home when it comes
to Fury all bets are off
one of the mechanisms that brings the
heroes together in the Marvels is a
mysterious process that causes Ms Marvel
Monica and Captain Marvel to switch
places whenever one of them Powers up at
one point Monica explains that their
powers are somehow intrinsically
connected okay so our powers are
entangled this police swapping team up
was teased long ago at the very end of
the Ms Marvel Disney plus series which
features an incredibly confused Carol
Danvers manifesting in Nikon household
being launched into kamala's closet and
finding herself surrounded by Captain
Marvel merchandise now it's clear that
the scene also appears in the Marvels
and it's expanded upon in the teaser
trailer as the experienced hero tries to
take in the fact that she's gone from
battling alien forces to standing in a
nerdy teenager's room
Kamala Khan changed the game when she
was first introduced to Marvel Comics in
2013. she's the first Muslim superhero
to ever headline her own comic book
series as well as the first Muslim
character to spearhead a live-action
Marvel property she's been a fresh
addition to the MCU especially in regard
to diversifying its roster of
superheroes the Disney plus series Ms
Marvel received heaps of praise for
these elements and it seems that the
Marvels will continue to honor the
character's cultural heritage the teaser
trailer for the upcoming Blockbuster
includes some scenes in which Nick Fury
and Monica Rambo visit kamala's family
and explain how their powers are
entangled with those of their daughter
the footage makes it clear that the Khan
family will play a key part in the movie
suggesting that the franchise will
continue to illustrate the importance of
her cultural background and how it
influences her as a superhero as she
matures
when news broke of Zoe Ashton joining
the Marvels Marvel Studios shrouded her
role in their typical secrecy only
revealing that she's playing the movie's
villain a press release from Marvel
accompanying the teaser trailer
confirmed that her character is an all
but unknown one from the comics a
gender-swapped version of the cree
General Dar Ben in the teaser trailer we
see her surrounded by an army of Cree
soldiers carrying a staff oddly
reminiscent of Ronan the accuser's
weapon and Guardians of the Galaxy more
on that in a bit and with a female
accuser trailing her if darben's name
doesn't immediately ring a bell that's
to be expected as the general is a
relatively obscure character from Marvel
Comics there's not much to know about
darben other than he's a general who
became an emperor for the cree Empire
the villain seems like the perfect sort
of obscure character for the studio to
bring into the MCU since there's lots of
room for reimagining darben to suit the
needs of the story
speaking of characters carrying
interesting staffs the teaser trailer
for the Marvel's shows Carol Danvers
getting a weapon of her own when we see
articular superhero group facing off
against an antagonist who appears to be
zowie Ashton's darben Captain Marvel
spectrum and Ms Marvel All Sport brand
new costumes but we can't help but
notice that Carol's holding a staff
behind her back pair that with the shot
of her swinging at the villain with a
hammer-like staff a few seconds later
and it all but confirms Captain Marvel
will wield a weapon in the movie's
climactic fight this weapon looks a lot
like a Cree cosmarod the weapon of
choice for the accusers MCU fans saw
Ronan wield one and Guardians of the
Galaxy and the trailer also shows
Ashton's villain carrying her own
cosmarod if it isn't the same one while
Captain Marvel is generally known more
for energy blasts than melee attacks we
can't wait to see what one of the mcu's
strongest Heroes is capable of with such
a powerful weapon in hand
[Music]